at least d wade's not involved in any  judging decisions this time around so  we're in good shape  all right  all i'm going to say is carl anthony  towns have 29 in the final  this place was electric  man this duck contest  was a six  man is there a five is that this is a  six i'll tell you what  we always have we have off here even  lebron james have all gained that's true  okay all right  over top and wins the  att slam down competition  you brought six out of nine you brought  your own uh i'm about to flip it  this duck contest right here was a solid  6.  [Laughter]  don't mess my dumb contest up come on  [Music]  that was nice though hey i can't do none  of that stuff them guys doing so i'm  just talking that was nice that was for  him good friends creativity special